oh god i'm back i made it back and i'm
still
alive
that
thing the old man had been tormenting me
for months following me trapping me god
knows where but i'm out now and yet
somehow that's just as bad let me
explain it all really started about a
hundred days ago i didn't start keeping
a tally of the days until a little after
things started to get strange but if i
think back the first sign happened on a
completely normal day i'd been stocking
up supplies with my eldest jimmy the
superstore in town had a limit on how
much you could spend in a single
transaction so we had to hit up a few
different places for canned food to
store in the bunker when we got back my
wife janie said she noticed a stain
upstairs sure enough she pointed it out
to me a slightly discolored patch on the
ceiling above our bed there wasn't much
there at first it just looked like a
little area of damp but i promised i'd
have a look at it over the weekend no
point wasting money on a handyman i
didn't think much of it i definitely
didn't think of it as anything to worry
about but i was so
so wrong the very next day i was outside
making a full inventory of everything in
the bunker we had everything all kinds
of practical equipment for any manner of
disaster not just food and water but
ropes and tools tents and sleeping bags
in case my family and i ever needed to
abandon the bunker and sleep in the wild
you see my whole life i'd been sure that
something was coming that out on the
horizon the end of the world was waiting
the way i saw it if civilization was one
day going to completely collapse then i
needed to prepare to make sure my family
and i made it through maybe part of it
was the fear too but when you're scared
of something you make yourself ready for
it right anyway it was while i was
listing the food rations and trying to
figure out just how many months we'd
survive on them when janie came in from
the house jake that stain on the
ceiling's getting bigger she declared
dragging me back indoors to show me as
far as i could see it hadn't changed
much since the day before the day after
that though
that was a different story janie didn't
have to point it out i could clearly
tell that something wasn't right about
that mark on our ceiling it wasn't just
bigger it was leaking but not just water
it didn't seem like it had come from a
leaky pipe somewhere in the house it was
a dark gooey substance almost like tar
that looked as if it had bled through
the surface of the ceiling from the
floor above
except that was the weird thing there
was no floor above and our bedroom was
on the highest level of the house apart
from the attic of course i climbed up on
the bed to take a closer look at the
greasy patch that was now the size of
two dinner plates wearing a pair of
thick gloves i reached up to wipe away
some of the muck immediately i could
smell something burning the fingers of
my glove had started to melt i ran into
the bathroom and pushed it off my hand
from the wrist by now this black ooze
had started to spread much further
across the ceiling reaching to just
above our bed janie told me she didn't
feel comfortable sleeping under whatever
that stuff was after it had just eaten
through my gloves i told her she didn't
need to worry it was dripping from the
ceiling and we'd be fine as long as we
just didn't touch it even then she still
opted to sleep on the couch that night i
had a really weird dream i was convinced
that i'd woken up in the middle of the
night restless and uneasy knowing janie
wasn't in the bed next to me that's when
i looked up at that slick patch of
darkness smeared across the ceiling but
there was something else there too
a face a grotesque face staring down at
me grinning a wide lipless smile i'm
sure it was a dream it had to be i'd
been putting off doing anything about
the stain that's why i dreamt about it
right
or maybe i was awake and it was just a
trick of the light what do you mean you
won't call someone janie asked
indignantly i just don't see the point i
argued we'd gotten into something of a
heated debate over what to do about the
goop on our ceiling i decided not to
tell her about my nightmare but even
then she was determined that i'd get a
handyman or someone to come and take a
look at it it'd be a waste of money i
tried to convince her why should we
shell out money for someone when i can
just get some disinfectant and clean it
up myself because you don't know what it
is even if you could just wipe it off it
might come back she yelled you'd rather
try to sort it out quickly so you can
get back to working on your bunker
that's to keep us safe i recorded look
jake i've humored it for long enough but
you spend more time out there than
looking after your own house janie
signed i refused i knew it was the
stubborn petty thing to do but i had
taken janie's comments about my bunker
to heart she'd never minded it before
always understood that i was only doing
it for us i think she saw the good place
it came from first and that meant more
than the actual work i'd done
stockpiling supplies and making sure
we'd have working plumbing after the
collapse later that day i caught both
jimmy and jake jr were lingering at the
bedroom door staring up at that thick
dark sludge on the ceiling the pair of
them were both keeping themselves behind
the door frame or gripping the door
itself like a shield my boys were scared
of it it was clear as day dad is the
house sick jake jr asked houses don't
get sick his older brother interjected
it's haunted there's a monster in the
attic right dad no monsters and the
house isn't sick i replied forcing a
smile to my sons i'll take care of it
about a week after the stain had first
appeared it was time for the monthly
drill every four weeks i'd gather my
family and we do a little practice just
in case the worst should happen at the
sound of an air horn we'd all have to
grab the bug-out bags i prepared for
everyone and run out to the bunker in
under five minutes the boys were always
eager it helped that they were both
young enough that we could treat it like
a game janie though
she didn't want to get involved trail
she stayed indoors trying to play it off
to the kids as if she was just busy but
the side glance she shot at me said
different and it was hard to avoid the
guilt that came with it that coupled
with seeing the boy's reaction to it
convinced me that it would just be
easier to have someone come take a look
at the slimy patch above the bed i
needed to go to town the next day
another supply run so i picked up the
number of a repair guy while i was out
even called him on the way home thinking
that would make it up to janie but as i
pulled up to the driveway i could hear
screaming coming from the house i raced
indoors and that's when i saw my wife
standing between our two boys and it it
was like a desiccated corpse an old man
with viscous black grease leaking out of
his decaying body the same substance
that had pooled on their bedroom ceiling
was now covering janie the old man had
her arm gripped in his hand the same
fluid coating her skin and burning her
she was shrieking and pain tears running
down her face as the boys cowered behind
her i froze i had no idea what to do so
i ran i'd acted out of panic and spent
the next week regretting it deeper than
any mistake i'd ever made i left my bug
out bag in the house and just blindly
sprinted straight for the bunker while
the screams of my wife and kids filled
the house in the days that followed
everything felt quiet but even then i
barely slept through a porthole in the
heavy metal door i watched the rear of
my home occasionally i'd catch a sight
of movement inside some tiny bit of
motion usually at night i kept hoping it
would be janie or one of the boys having
found a place to hide and then making
their way out the back door to me but
every time it was only ever him the old
man slung through my family's home
staring out at me with lidless eyes his
jaw locked in a twisted grin like he was
enjoying tormenting me a sharp knock on
the bunker woke me up from the short
restless sleep i sat bolt upright
immediately expecting that thing to be
on the other side it was the handyman
i'd called a few days earlier
it seemed like such a trivial matter now
ah there was no answer at the front he
explained to me hope you don't mind me
coming around the back your side gate
was open barely paying him any mind i
dash towards the house there's no sign
of the old man but i couldn't find
janie's body or the two boys is anywhere
i went to grab my bug out bag only to
run into the handyman in the hallway
before i could urge him to run to leave
the house the old man's face appeared
pushing through another slick oily black
puddle in the wall grabbing the other
man and dragging him in as i bolted for
the door heading for the woods was my
safest option no my only option if i
went to the police there was no way
they'd believe such an outlandish story
they'd probably suspect me of murdering
my family or think i was crazy if i told
them a zombie had attacked my home that
got me thinking what the hell was that
old man he couldn't have been a zombie
for start there was only one he wasn't
turning people but there was something
off about his actions almost like they
weren't mindless shuffling attacks there
was intent behind them he was patient
camping out in the woods brought me no
joy even with all the supplies in my bag
whenever i tried to sleep i just lay
awake for hours thinking of my family
and the grotesque face of the old man
every sound in the night the wind
rustling the leaves animals cracking
sticks underfoot in my mind everything i
heard was him getting closer and closer
and pretty soon he did i started keeping
watch during the nights and i'd catch
sight of a silhouetted figure in the
darkness every few days he would
reappear he'd never get close enough to
attack me just enough to force me to
pack up camp again and relocate until
one night i could hear the sound of
gurgle breathing outside my tent i
reached for my flashlight casting its
light over the walking corpse that stood
outside it recoiled from the bright
light but as its decaying face
illuminated i ran leaving my campsite
and bag where they were
i didn't care i just sprinted through
the woods branches scratching at me like
the decrepit bony fingers of the old man
clawing at my skin i could hear water
running barely seeing the stream in my
flashlight before my foot sank into it
wading through i crawled out on the
opposite bank cold wet and still trying
to get away the days that followed were
hard with no supplies i had to survive
on what little i had left in my pockets
my best bet i thought was to keep hiking
keep putting distance between myself and
him and for a while it was working or i
thought it was it wasn't until i came
across tracks not like animal tracks not
even an ordinary human's footprints they
were thick with that black burning tar
melting into the forest ground in the
shape of the old man's foot i'd gone
around in the circle this whole time i
thought i was getting away from him i
had just been going around and around
when i stumbled upon what was still left
in my campsite i should have been
overjoyed but instead my heart dropped
through to the bottom of my stomach i
shouldn't have stopped there that's what
he wanted but i was hungry exhausted and
i just needed to sleep that was when he
got me i woke up to the stench of some
burning substance only to find something
locked tightly around my ankle one of
the old man's hands another one of his
greasy gateways had opened on the nearby
tree and he was pulling me inside the
pain was what hit me first before i
could even get a good look at where i
was or what was around me instead all i
felt was the most excruciating agony i'd
ever experienced looking down i saw why
the old man had two of his bony clawed
fingers hooking into my ankle not just
holding me by it his fingers were going
through and it hurt the black sludge was
still dripping from him and on to me the
more of it passed through my clothes
touching my skin and mixing with my
blood the more i felt it burning digging
in the fingers of his other hand the old
man pulled apart the bones in my lower
leg like the wishbone of a turkey only
with a much louder and far more painful
snap the shock left me unconscious again
lost and now with half of my leg
forcibly ripped away i had no idea where
i was and for some strange reason the
old man had left me to wander around
freely although i'd soon find out why it
hurt just to move but i wrapped my leg
up and crawled my way around the vast
labyrinth even if i still had my bag
which had a compass in it it still would
have been impossible to navigate i tried
to take shelter under my jacket hiding
and setting up as much of a camp as i
could every time i thought i was safe a
greasy black puddle would begin to form
on the nearest wall and that same
decaying face with a lipless grin came
through it but that was why he let me
wander just so he could make sure i
never slept my suffering was a gain to
him the longer i spent there the more
tired i became through lack of sleep
searing pain of my forcibly amputated
leg and the fear of trying to keep away
from the old man i started to get low i
had no way of escaping even if i tried
stepping through one of those black
puddles it would just corrode me but i
started to think maybe that would have
been better getting home and having to
live without janie if she would still be
gone jimmy and jake jr weren't going to
be waiting for me if i somehow managed
to make it back i had been keeping a
tally of all the days since i'd left
adding on the week when the stain first
appeared it had been 90 days i couldn't
take it anymore i just wanted it over i
didn't see the point to continue this
torture i wanted to leave and i wanted
my family back the only way to get both
was to let the old man get me but he
must have known i was looking for him
every time i yelled out into the
confusing maze i was stuck in i never
got an answer he wouldn't come and find
me i couldn't tell if he knew how badly
i was suffering stuck here and just
wanted to prolong that or if he'd gotten
bored of me eventually after over
another week without rest i tried to
sleep again and that was when he came
for me only i didn't bother to run this
time as i saw the corpse-like creature
shambling towards me black grease
covering its body i closed my eyes and
waited for it to happen when i came back
to consciousness my vision was filled
with nothing but bright white light i
thought that maybe this was it that the
old man had caught me and decided to put
an end to the chasing and torture for a
few brief seconds i was certain that i
was dead what else are you supposed to
think when you wake up squinting at a
blinding light but i wasn't dead and
hadn't been delivered to the afterlife
and i wasn't still in that horrible
labyrinth that nightmarish place i had
just been for over a month feeling the
cold hard ground something in the pit of
my stomach told me i was back in the
real world still unable to see properly
i raised a hand to block out some of the
glare the sounds of heavy boots clomping
towards me two pairs of gloved hands
reached out and grabbed my arms dragging
me out of the path of the intense light
as they did i started blinking away the
spots in my vision and that's when i saw
masses of machinery and the creature the
old man caught in the beams of three
white spotlights i looked up at the
people who had saved me a pair of
figures and tactical gear their uniforms
bearing the insignia of something called
the scp foundation as grateful as i was
to this foundation for pulling me out of
that nightmare and as glad as i was to
still be alive couldn't help but feel
more and more uneasy as they debriefed
me maybe it was just how interested they
seemed in my encounter with the old man
or
scp-106 as they called it as i described
what had happened in the lengthy debrief
or it might have been how quick they
were to shrug off what the old man had
done to my family whatever it was i
didn't trust them even though they
seemed to believe my story recalling it
all made me think of jamie and my two
boys again i used to be so afraid of the
world ending spent all that time and
money making sure i was ready for when
the end finally hit but it had snuck up
on me it didn't matter that the earth
was still turning my world was gone and
i figured that must have been why the
old man kept me alive it could have
easily killed me if it really wanted to
but it let me live on not just so it
could torture me but so i'd be alive to
know my family was gone it wasn't long
after i realized this that the
foundation offered me something medicine
they said would help me forget about it
all if i didn't take it i'd at least get
to remember what i used to have but also
live with the pain of not having it
anymore that was the old man's real
torture so i had to as i washed down the
pill with a swig of water i thought back
to janie and my sons with tears in my
eyes wishing them goodbye before they
were really gone forever now go and
check out scp-106 containment breach and
scp-106 caused a school lockdown for
further background information on the
sadistic and sinister anomaly as well as
a few other situations unsuspecting
victims found themselves being hunted by
the old man and whether or not they too
live to tell about it